I follow one on Instagram yeah excuse me
what you [__] don't what me
what did you do
[Music]
so uh in Vancouver a prison Union
spokesperson said that a pigeon carrying
a miniature backpack filled with drugs
was captured last week and it had meth
in the backpack do that mini backpack so
cute yeah I was just visualize that with
a mini backpack that was nothing it
might have been blue do you think he
like sags a little bit too like all the
cool Birds
I bet she was that pigeon from the
Animaniacs working for the the mob the
god pigeons yeah no yeah the good
feathers yeah good feathers
so uh the prison spokesman uh
spokesperson said that a fabric backpack
tied to the pigeon contained crystal
meth uh he said it was he was told by
officers that the gray bird was spotted
with its unusual cargo on December 29th
in a yard at the facility and they set
up a trap to catch it so they knew about
its root huh and what do the guards do
do they [__] put them in a little
pitch of handcuffs take off a backpack
and [__] and he's got a little pigeon
[__]
um Wing cuffs Wing cuffs oh I like that
Wing cuffs it has to be both dude yes
maybe feet cups he has a little [__]
mug shot can I see a picture of the mini
handcuffs
can I see a picture of the uh suspect
yeah his inmates are smart man I wonder
how long they've been doing birds are
smarter yeah holy [__] that means that's
probably like an age-old thing from like
they've been doing it yeah oh yeah 1776.
spokesperson said that in recent years
prison officers have been on the lookout
for drones carrying drugs and other
Contraband but it was the first time in
its 13 years as a corrections officer
that he heard of a live bird being used
so this was the first for this
particular dude my initial reaction was
shocked because of all the advancements
in technology and the number of drones
we've seen the fact that it's tied to a
pigeon is abnormal
damn people are actually flying drones
into prison and dropping off drugs too
that's pretty wild they're trafficking
guns with drones remember we did the
story with the guy had like plastic bags
and guns yeah there were like 12 guns in
and they were trying to fly across the
border and stuff like that that's a
Canada crashed into a tree I mean I
think it'd be easier to spot it's just
Target bags
it looks like a Glock it's the Ikea blue
bag how do they find them until like two
people are like does that pigeon have a
I know that's that's what happened
people were just like looking at Pigeon
they're like is that a backpack so then
they like worked on trying to like
capture it like oh my God the backpack's
so cute
he's going to school he said Smugglers
would have had difficulty getting a bird
to land in a price location compared to
a drone but he suggested they had gone
quote old school because of officers
increasing awareness of drug smuggling
drones which he said uh they were
encountering daily wow so I wonder how
they trained the pigeon to like land at
a certain place sesame seeds no I don't
know
that's why the fact that they have
drones daily it's crazy daily and they
he said they have gone backward in
technology maybe that's because of all
the work we have done with drone
interdiction that they are trying to
find new ways to get Contraband in
without being detected they were going
so Ham on drones that they were able to
[__] counter drones so that they had
to go back to the counter drone unit
yeah but they were like we're gonna [__]
them up with pigeons and stuff we don't
have a pigeon unit they need to just
train pigeons to regurgitate like
freaking if you want to go real on
school it's like what do we do they
bring in Mike Tyson
because if you think about it like the
jails have like dudes from all different
gangs right so if all different people
are different gangs all other people are
all trying to bail them out they're
[__] digging with spoons at night
everyone's trying to send drugs in it
must be like the worst place in the
world like everyone's trying to bail
them out it's crazy and they're still
succeeding because there's tons of drugs
in jail drugs [__] instant noodles
cell phones all kinds of [__] what they
need to do is get an eagle because every
time there's a [__] pigeon like
American Eagle comes and goes America
[__] and then he catches them yeah Oh I
thought you meant an eagle on the bad
guy side because the guards would be
like oh [__]
that's so funny dude just the pitch we
got to get an eagle because all the
guards would be like
[Laughter]
what do we do sir don't shoot it [__]
just paint the pigeon to look like an
eagle ferrets
a monkey
Little Monkeys how's it gonna fly into
the prison no but little monkeys you
could just throw them over you could
catapult the little monkey all right
over the fence so you gotta get a
catapult
monkey has a little parachute right so
he catapults monkey parachutes down
[__]
right you got to teach somebody to pull
a shoot he has little a poo hat and he
takes out the Apu hat and then there's
meth right there he goes oh and he gives
the stuff and he puts it back on and
then he that's a really good idea Baby
thank you or he has like multiple hats
and then it turns into three hats and he
does
and then the guards Put the gun down
exactly
yeah so that's the back of the pigeon
they got some e and [__] that's [__]
sewn on to him oh and then that's not a
backpack looks like that's smart that
they made it the same color as the
pigeon I thought Matthew's like crystals
yeah wow maybe it has both that's not
what I visualized in my head holy [__]
I was looking for the JanSport no yeah
the two-tone
you're looking for a mini
Sport with a navy blue and then the bait
the brown on the bottom people are
signing it show like that with white out
or the Everest bag
believe it that was a wasted Opportunity
by these robbers imagine if the they
start using that guy that you know when
you go outside Staple Center there's a
guy playing with those neon toys that
just fly up
he just stood closer to the prison hey
what's that guy doing
who actually buys those that's what I'm
saying what if their whole purpose is
just drug trafficking we had no idea if
you guys can have a sidekick animal what
would you get cool good question
[__] Eagle because you know like when
you played World of Warcraft when you
were like a nerd
um you would be a hunter class and you
can like train one of the animals like
you could catch a [__] lion or
something and they could be your like
hunting companion some people could have
Eagles like the Mongolians you know if I
had a side pet yeah and just to follow
up on Ryan's question like just as a pet
or like to commit crimes
to commit crimes that would be even
better
damn I wonder Fox
yeah yeah why it [__] because they get
everywhere and I used to have a pet fox
in London and I miss him and then they
get everywhere they can sneak into
places it was just a straight pit dog
straight Fox you fed that's not your
past that's my pet you used to walk with
me I used to feed him what's a stray Fox
yeah
he'll come to me you walk with you you
would walk with me down the street yeah
she likes possums out there they're just
all over the place oh really oh wow you
make it sound like really he loved me it
was a really special connection you know
yeah would you like to demean it anymore
yeah guy like it was really important
moment in my life now you have a stray
gel I know he's less work than the fox
I mean I mean I've always wanted a
monkey yeah
you want a monkey or specific any kind
of specific I'm not trying to get
canceled for for many people out there
but yeah like those [__] like little
chimps and stuff like that that [__]
know how to like you know just do stuff
you know they got like little
personalities that they don't want to
climb on you and [__] but they got
opposable thumb so they'll like grab
[__] yeah
a realistic one would be like a raccoon
I like raccoon oh that's cool you like
raccoon I think they're [__] cool I
follow one on Instagram yeah excuse me
what you [__] don't what me
what did you do he lives with another
the dog family
like he plays with the dog they do all
kinds of cute [__] at home yeah that one
yeah speaking of animals on Instagram I
found this page where um it's an
armadillo and they're like little dogs
dude they're so cute that's what you
want in armadillo that's pretty cool but
like shoot a BB gun at it yeah yeah you
can shoot bullets it'll be fine you know
it'll protect me they'll take a bullet
for me no but they're like they act like
little dogs you could pet it they come
up to you and I didn't know armadillos
were so cute so that's my new thing on
Instagram dude these days I've been
wanting I'm in between a cap the
Capybaras or the wombat I'm I'm stuck
between a woman that's a dope yeah but I
heard that the Cappy Bears the those
guys are nocturnal so they keep you up
at night yeah what a bummer dude can't
have one now it would also be sick to
this is Impractical but to have a
[__] sea otter I don't know if I need
to carry like a backpack of water
everywhere just so I can like it's kind
of cool to have anything sea based so it
could save you from drowning or you
could just blown up and it just like
rolls up but you like drop it and it
like goes in the ocean and you can't
retrieve it
yeah but you need that to retreat that
one
a furry sea creature or a smooth one
like a dolphin
or alligator or alligator I like
alligators well I mean if we're allowed
to go that far and have [__] pet
whales I mean I'm down for a whale but
you can't commit a crime with a whale
Are you seriously killer whales how do
you do one with the wind you dispose of
bodies
it just keeps you that's smart you're
like you pirate submarines with whales
body disposal you know or you get a bear
because they're really good at breaking
into homes and playing pianos
thank you thank you Anthony
and nobody gets mad you know that was a
very cute topic yeah that's wholesome
that's adorable thank you we are
re-monetized
[Music]